Benign Causes Depression and anxiety.
I learned about a bit less connections.
There were few that were really
challenging for me because I realized
how much I recognize them in myself.
So one of the hardest,
I'll tell you a story about something
else first,
but when I was in 2009 on Christmas Eve,
it makes it even sadder.
The story happened on Christmas Eve,
so I used to live on junk food.
I used to eat appallingly and on
Christmas Eve,
2009,
I went into my local KFC at lunchtime
and I turned up and I gave my order,
which is so disgusting.
I can't even repeat it.
And the guy behind the counter said,
are Johann so glad you're here.
Wait a minute.
It was like,
okay,
so you walked off and he came back with
all the other staff and they bought me a
massive Christmas card and they'd
written it to our best customer and so I
was looking at this and my heart sank.
I thought,
this isn't even the fried chicken shop.
I come to the most.
It was very unfortunate that low point,
but we all know,
right?
Junk food has taken over our diet.
It's not admittedly to the extreme the
eyebrows,
but junk food is increasingly dominating
our diets and it's making us physically
sick.
One thing that really shocked me in the
research is that there's.
There's really good evidence.
There's something similar has happened
with our minds,
but I kind of junk values have taken
over our minds and they've made us
mentally sick,
but the thousands of years now,
philosophers have said,
if you think life is about money and
status and and showing off,
you're going to feel terrible right?
From Confucius on down people that
rewarding is that,
but weirdly nobody had actually
scientifically investigated it until an
incredible man.
I got to know your professor,
Tim Kasser,
who's at Knox University in Illinois,
so professor cass a new.
When it comes to human motivation,
this basically,
to put it crudely,
two kinds of human motivation,
right?
Imagine you play the piano.
If you play the piano in the morning
because you love it and it gives you
joy,
that's an intrinsic motivation.
You're not doing it to get something out
a bit.
You're just doing it because that thing
gives you joy right now.
Imagine you play the piano not because
it gives you joy,
but in a dive bar to pay the rent or
because your parents are really
pressuring you to be a piano maestro or
I'd know to impress a man might be some
weird piano fetishist,
right?
That would be an extrinsic reasons to
play the piano.
You're not doing it for the experience
itself.
You're doing it to get something out.
You're doing it at one remove.
You're doing it to get something out of
the experience.
Now we're all a mixture of intrinsic and
extrinsic values obviously,
and we change throughout our lives,
but professor cass discovered some
really fascinating things.
The first thing is the more your life is
dominated by extrinsic values,
the more you're doing things,
not because you think they're important,
but because of how you'll look to other
people,
how you're seem on the outside,
the more likely you are to become
depressed and anxious.
It's a quite significant effect.
Has Been found in 22 studies with
depression and 14 studies with anxiety.
Now,
there are many reasons.
I'll give you just one.
One of the things we know is that
something that's a real source of joy in
human life since really necessary have
what are called flow states right there.
Moments when you're doing something you
really love.
For me,
it's writing for someone else.
It might be running.
It's definitely not that for me or you
know,
whatever.
Uh,
when you time seems to collapse,
you're totally in the moment of what
you're doing and you're just,
you're flowing right?
Extreme extrinsic values massively
disrupt your ability to get into flow
states.
Imagine you're playing the piano.
Imagine the guys playing the piano for
intrinsic reasons,
right?
Because it gives them joy.
Now imagine suddenly has to think,
am I the best piano player in New York
City today?
Who's better than me?
How are these people listening to me?
How are they judging me?
Am I going to get paid for this?
You can see how it would jolt you out of
the flow state,
right?
When you think extrinsically,
you get jolted out of flow state,
there are many reasons why extrinsic
values make us feel bad and they ruin
the quality of your relationships.
They crowd out intrinsic values.
There's all sorts of things going on,
but press castles also showing that
extrinsic values have been taking over
our culture.
We are becoming more and more dominated
by these extrinsic values.
This we are immersed in this way of
thinking for the moment we're born more
18 month old children recognize the
Mcdonald's m,
the know that own surname.
We are pickled in advertising messages
telling us that life is about living
extrinsically,
right?
Imagine an advert that told you,
you know what?
You're great.
You look fine.
You smell nice,
you're amazing.
You don't need anything more today.
That would be the worst advert that ever
been done.
Right?
Advertising is the ultimate frenemy is
always telling you,
oh babe,
I love you.
It's just,
you know,
didn't stink right now what professor
Castillo's showed as he puts it is at
some level we all know this,
right?
Everyone watching this knows you're not
going to lie on the on the last day of
your life.
You will not lie there and think about
all the things you bought,
right?
You will not think about all the hours
you put in at the office.
You will think about moments of deep
meaning and connection,
but as professor Cassar puts it,
we live in a machine that is constantly
diverting us from what is meaningful
about life.
There's a wonderful experiment is done
before Professor Castle's work,
but I think it really illustrates this
and it was done.
Nineteen 78.
It's really simple experiment.
You get a lot of five year olds and you
put them in a sandpit and you split them
into two groups.
The first group is shown to
advertisements for specific toy.
Whatever the 19,
78 equivalent of peppa pig was,
right,
and the second group is shown show no
adverts and at the end of it they give
all the kids a choice.
They said,
okay,
kids go choice.
Now you can either play with a nice boy
who doesn't have the toy from the out of
it or you can play with a nasty boy
who's got the toy.
The kids who didn't see the ad mostly
choose the nice boy without the toy and
the kids who saw the ad,
mostly twos,
the nasty boy who's got the toy,
so just to advertisements to prime those
children to choose and inanimate lump of
plastic over kindness and connection.
We are all being driven by way more
advertising than that everyday,
right?
Anyone watching this and I would include
myself in that,
he stayed late at work,
do something they don't want to do to
buy something they don't need rather
than go be home with their kids.
Maybe you've fallen prey to that dynamic
and professor Kessler has really shown
this way that we've got to.
We've got to unpick these junk values,
these junk values,
what we've been fed for so long.
There are kind of KFC for the soul and
they're making us feel terrible.